on retrouva putsch à notre envoyé
spécial de gulliver craag
je suis devant la morgue de boudhha ou
encore tous les jours des dizaines de
personnes viennent à la recherche de
leurs proches et il y à des corps qui
sortent de set manquées définira qui
sont organisés plus de 400 morts abuja
seul selon la mairie alors antonio
gutiérrez qui s'est exprimé non loin
d'ici à là où il y avait une fosse
commune dont les corps ont déjà été
exhumés il a dit bien sûr qu' il
faudrait que la cour pénale
internationale se saisisse de ces
accusations de crimes de guerre et
évidemment pour cela il est absolument
capital que le maximum d'évidence soient
recueillies et que ce soit fait de la
manière le plus crédible possible et
c'est pour cela qu'il y à une équipe de
dix huit gendarmes qui sont venus ici
des gendarmes français qui sont venus
ici pour aider avec les enquêtes ils
sont là depuis presque deux semaines en
fait et ils procèdent à des objets des
prises deux adn pour identifier les
corps et aussi pour essayer de
déterminer les causes de leur mort ils
font des études et et cela pourrait
t'aider je pense que pour les autorités
ukrainiennes c'est très important
d'avoir cette coopération internationale
aux enquêtes qui bien sûr donne plus de
crédibilité aux résultats de ce qui est
et ce soir il faut l'espérer un jour
présenté devant la cour pénale
internationale